ich hör auf mit galaxy hallo ich meine
lieben freund und herzlich willkommen
zur weiteren folge minecraft galaxy
direkt im anschluss an ein update for
sales bei jobcentern mutter habe ihn
interessiert uns alle nicht direkt das
kann etwas umgefallen
bei mir im haus bei meinem papa ich
werde mich in dieser einen direkt im
anschluss an die andere folge wollte ich
sagen ich werde mich in dieser folge
immer noch damit beschäftigen statt ganz
so ein bisschen aufpasst hat ihn nicht
angegangen da links gebäudereihe das
leben
ich werde mich in dieser folge noch so
ein bisschen hiermit überall
beschäftigen ich brauche das brauche die
sakura wood das land ich nämlich einfach
ich war das eigentlich auf die ecken
rauen aber hier ging das ja jetzt nicht
irgendwie nicht mehr
ja was soll da muss er dieses andere
portieren ich geh jetzt mal ganz kurz
kennen damit ihr ein bisschen was zählt
nein
konkret liegt mit einer der wand aber
das ist egal
ich möchte in dieser folge erreichen
dass ich meine farm weitestgehend fertig
kriege hier brauche ich noch rotach es
stimmt ich wollte das wird wohl damit
ich nicht dass ich jetzt noch stärker
wenn ich irgendwie unter springer.com
komm komm komm ich brauch mal was zu
essen und meine minions könnte ich auch
mal wieder einholen dass die mir dann
auch so ein bisschen das haus grübeln
dieses ist ja immer ganz witzig nicht
nur für die einmal wieder zurückholen
baldini war sie die bleiben ja nie da
die die spawn ja immer irgendwie das
sind uns auch noch mal eine ganze sache
wenn man das richtig
ich hasse dieses geräusch von spinnen
so ich packe ich mal ganz kurz da oben
in die t strahlen bekommt alle eine
super tolle kiste von extra angefertigt
die ist voll cool ich brauche noch ein
bisschen wird hiervon dann setze ich das
gleich da oben als begrenzung dran für
das glas damit das glas nicht in der
luft schwebt also ein bisschen gelegt
hier
nein
ja das wird jetzt in dem merkmal des
landes total mit der sonne so ihr kommt
jetzt alle hin so das stimmt ja schon
mal
dann kommt hier an die seite kommt hier
das hier so hin und da oben kommt das so
hin und das möchte ich in dieser folge
nämlich schaffen
eigentlich wollte ich ein paar bäume ein
paar möbel machen und ich wollte da
draußen hat den tollen tisch ersetze
aber ich finde keine coolen tische
zeitung wollte ich mal eine türklingel
machen uns ein paar kleine kleinigkeiten
die ihm in die kommentare geschrieben
habt und was mir auch oft in kommentare
geschrieben wird ist das ganze projekt
zu ende ist also das wird wohl bisher
bei jedem großen projekt so öfters in
die kommentare geschrieben also auch bei
ihr und auch bei war und alles bei was
nicht so oft da war es halt zu ende wenn
man stirbt aber wir haben hier keinen
festen termin festgesetzt
außer wenn jetzt irgendwer sagen würde
ich hör auf mit galaxy oder irgendwie
sowas dann weil sie nicht dann ist das
für den mac natürlich dadurch vorbei
aber mir ist bei mir ist es zurzeit so
ich habe noch ein paar pläne in diesem
projekt ich will zum beispiel doch
dieses große teil jeder weiß nicht was
ich machen soll ich also einen riesigen
unterirdischen garten machen aber ich
weiß nicht genau wie ich das alles
hinkriegt machen das nicht genau ich
habe immer so tolle pläne und als
endlich wenn ich die umsätze sieht total
scheiße aus das ist halt sondern
komische angewohnheit von mir auch
nichts mehr
bin ich noch ein bisschen vom auch schon
wieder alles voll
sehr schön manchmal gleich zwei äxte ich
meine so lang für mich in einem projekt
pläne vorhanden sind die ich umsetzen
möchte da bleibe ich da auch drin
bei mir war es so ein megaprojekt nach
der zeit dann hatte ich da diese ganzen
tollen maschinen und es wurde nach alles
widmann hat ein jetpack bei mir so ich
kann hier um fliegen wie mit einer
fledermaus at s ok das cool ist dass ich
direkt in einen der ersten folgen der im
fledermaus am start hatte weiß ich jetzt
nicht aber es ist quasi auch schon
sonderschichten durch dieses dass man
eine fledermaus ist aber ich meine ich
irgendwann noch so tools habe ich das
immer bei anderen die machen sich dann
so waffen die unendlich lange halten und
unendlich stark sie nun alles da denke
ich mir so das möchte ich eigentlich gar
nicht machen weil dadurch das man sowas
hat find ich geht der ganze reiz an dem
projekt so ein bisschen verloren
es ist natürlich cool wenn ihr da einem
zuschauer und die zugkraft der ist ok er
hat die reggae und die waffe aber wenn
ich mir so was machen würde würde ich
mir sowas nicht machen weil weiß ich
nicht ich bin nicht so der fan davon
dass ich dann so die heftigsten sachen
habe ich möchte es lieber so für ein
normaler mensch sein
keine ahnung was ich schon wieder lava
überhaupt keinen plan was ich da wieder
rede ihr denkt euch wahrscheinlich
gerade was labert ich hoffe ihr versteht
mich da so ein bisschen meine meinung
gegenüber
ich möchte nicht somit der ideale
krassesten sachen machen weil ich weiß
dass dann so der spiel reiz für mich
verloren wird dann denke ich mir so ok
spielte galaxy moment ich könnte
eigentlich im game 1 gehen wir so ein
bisschen was bauen weil ich weiß dass zb
mit einer smart reader kann man sich
sachen 1 melden und dann irgendwie ärzte
verdoppelt und alles mögliche ich weiß
wir das ganze baut aber dass ich hab da
einfach nicht so die nicht zu dem bock
drauf es wird immer so gefordert dass
ich das mal ab dass das mache aber es
ist für mich es ergibt für mich keinen
sinn in der materie
ich mache auch schon wieder alles kaputt
jetzt gerade
sowas macht für mich dann mehr spaß wenn
ich einfach mein haus ein bisschen
schöner mauer
ich mag es war total kaputt sich das
ganze wasser was darunter kommen aber
naja das ist kollateralschaden damit
muss man leben so
moment noch weg so hieß doch ab
diese fließt das letztlich ab einer
firma oder
noch einer
noch einer noch einer soll jetzt aber
alter was kann da viel wasser raus
ok cool so cool war das jetzt nicht aber
versteht wie total die rohrbrüche jeder
folge berichten rohr bei uns hier nicht
so toll
auch hier kommt auch ein bisschen wehmut
und dann war es also eigentlich schon
mit dem fahrrad oder mehr brauchen wir
gar nicht so ist ihr noch irgendwas
heißen ich habe jetzt das hier aus
diesem holz gemacht dass ich das mache
ist ein paar aber ich mache ich habe
alles aus palmroth einfach alles aber
eigentlich damit einheitlich ist muss
das auch ist hier aus palm- oder bauen
passt das ja gar nicht ins gesamtbild
das da oben passt eigentlich auch gar
nicht so willkommen auch paul mudter
dann muss ich mir da unten mal was neues
holen wir noch ein bisschen was ich
wollte eigentlich schon längst mit
möbeln anfang märz wieder bei neun
minuten scheiße ich kann ich meine
ganzen pläne umsetzen wenig behindert
ich hatte dann auf volleyball mutig
vollidiot machen könnt ihr aber bescheid
sagen hier man so hier kommt noch ein
bisschen was dran
ich weiß nicht wie ich das finden soll
die ganze fahrt jetzt natürlich noch mit
einer haube fertig gemacht möchte dann
ich glaube hier
ali ronhof eine ironische [ __ ]
hahaha ich habe das gefühl ich lasse
dazwischen einfach mal so ein paar
blöcke immer dass das hier so ein
bisschen heller ist oder ich mache meine
decke ihnen die so kronleuchter so diese
lampen weil ich glaubte es helmes dann
wächst das ja immer besser bei
tageslicht mexes am allerbesten aber
desto höher der level ist desto besser
wächst was ja bericht ich mich mal bitte
wenn ich da irgendwie ist wieder neben
der scheiße verzapfen mehr glaubt dass
irgendwer
ich kann ein vergleich mal gucken ob
diese lampen schwer zu machen sind immer
ganz cool m100 für lampen cool war da
eigentlich soll ich machen die sind so
ein bisschen schwieriger nahm volumina
glaubst du dass allein die sind ja
vieles kompliziert glas da kann ja
ferien glas nehmen das natürlich cool
red stage ist auch nicht so schwer
da brauchen wir nur diesen klaus kastner
habe ich irgendwo klaus daun
ich habe auch keinen bock das team was
bond redstone
ich mache das erstmal mit fackeln
abzufackeln ich habe fast gar keine
männer dann mache ich mir noch mal ganz
kurz kisten nicht an ansätze sind auch
schon bald genügen so fackeln
ich glaube schon richtig lange einfach
ohne fackeln rum
das will man so aufgefallen nein
so sagte tack
dann kommt hier noch an jede zweite
stelle eine
so hier auch
dann wird das ganze jemand ein bisschen
heller gemacht
stimmt das denn jetzt ja das stimmt
sogar überall rum ist ein und jetzt
kommen hier noch daneben wie die kisten
dran dann geht hier weizen angepflanzt
und alles mögliche
das könnte ich auch noch jetzt mal eben
schnell machen so was habe ich denn da
alles für sie zu darüber lernen müssen
die wollte ich dahin pflanzen die die
die die die sein dass sie zu wenig dazu
zu viel sex up make a strawberry ich
habe schon das ist schon alles viel ich
hab jetzt schon 91810 wollte ich ja im
moment an einer eine art von zietz hatte
ich noch ein pflanz das jetzt erstmal an
alles
ich mache das jetzt erst mal so ein
bisschen was das überhaupt mal wächst
man verteile ich dass nachher oft die
reihen
hier noch ein bisschen was oder ich
mache das wirklich so dass dennoch die
kann ich tanzen oder ich mache das
wirklich noch dass da quasi so ein paar
reihen noch dazwischen machen weil wenn
ich schon sehr wie viel strawberry ich
allein schon ab dann wird das vielleicht
gar nicht alles ausreichend hier kann
ich eigentlich hin setzen naja gut
die werden dann wohl irgendwie schon
wachsen hoffe ich mal
ich würde einfach sagen das war's dann
auch schon mit der heutigen folge wieder
ich hoffe euch jetzt gefallen die folgen
sind jetzt wie gesagt aber noch ein
bisschen kürzer weil ich das ganze vor
produziert muss wir haben die farben
fertig der nächsten folge werde ich mich
da nur möbel kümmern oder will ich sagen
es euch gefallen hat dass ein wert ab
wir sehen es morgen wieder und tschüss
morgen sie uns gar nicht wieder ein
galaxy
morgen kommt erstmal der kontakt über
ein paar fragen von euch die könnte mir
jetzt in die kommentare schreiben
da wär ich davon ein paar fragen dann
nehmen sie wird übermorgen an galaxy
weil morgen ich möchte nicht jeden tag
alex übrigens hat wahrscheinlich schon
mitbekommen und